cette année le château de Versailles
fête ses 400 ans monument historique
incontournable et lieu touristique
majeur dans les Yvelines pourquoi pas
cette année offrir à vos proches un bon
dans le temps avec un billet pour le
château depuis 1610 le château a vu
défiler les rois de France de Louis XI à
louis- Philippe c'est finalement au 19e
siècle que le lieu se transforme en
musée lieu touristique incontournable du
département avec 6 millions de visit en
2022 les expositions permanentes et
éphémères se multiplient et il y en a
pour tous les goûts de la galerie des
glaces au grands appartements du roi en
passant par le hameau de laarine ou
encore le bassin et les fontaines le
château de Versailles recorge de lieux
et d'histoire à découvrir et avec des
billets pour tous les budgets ce cadeau
original raviera aussi bien les curieux
que les passionnés
d'histoire